thank you and yeah thank you that you
all made this to the last presentation
this is really cool so yeah today as you
can see I would like to talk about topic
that we actually face a lot doing our
client engagement and this is namely
actually to put data science models into
production and yeah so I actually had a
slide for myself so I'm at as I set as
your set I'm a data scientist at -
laughs I'm based in the Berlin office
and this is my github account you can
find the code of the demo that I'm also
doing on this account and yeah this is
my twitter handler as well all right
okay so let's start with defining the
problem that we actually have with our
clients so let's say yeah this is a this
is a full stack data scientist and he
has a background and statistics oh look
sweat nerdy right and he's just got been
hired by a company which hasn't had data
signs before and the company wants to be
more data driven right so like many
companies today because yeah you know
data science is cool big data is cool
right and okay what do you first as a
data sciences well of course you start
digging in the data all right so you
review the data you clean the data and
of course you're trying to create
meaningful features of it and as you can
see on this slide the data amount is
huge so it's happening for a data
scientist so the next step of course as
a data sign is probably you're building
a machine learning motor right so you
cross relate your model and then you
create a actually you create a perfect
prediction model the question is then
what happens next right
usually at most companies you probably
prepare a presentation and you probably
present those findings to your
management and your team right so who
have you actually work as a data
scientist in a company right okay it's
not so much
well of course I like this picture here
they think it's actually cool so your
management likes it and you're showing
your results and oh memos and actually
yeah your model is really solving a
business problem after presentation
after your presentation you're like this
guy you know it you know what the brexit
is right so everyone probably heard of
the bridge you heard of the Praxis so
you're super enthusiastic like nature
Faraj that your work would change - all
right and you think that it's just
matter of days that you work with go
live and will be used by a thousand of
users but like and like the practice set
you face reality so you realize that it
takes some times right and and it's
actually a very long time now so as
actually all those guys they thought
that they could go out earlier from from
the European Union but this is not
probably going to happen well yeah in
reality this is actually what happens
so at many engagement with our clients
we've seen that all this with the
results that we created are going to be
on use and they're literally thrown into
this trash can here so that's why I call
it smart because it has many smart
results all right so what is the problem
why models are not being put into
production well we've seen that data
scientists speak different languages so
different design in speak for example
our Python or sus right we're sorry
genius they speak like rubies with or or
go so if you're a tenant Peter wants to
talk yesterday he always said that data
science is not not like sir engineering
so this is also here the case and
basically it's also not about the a
programming language problem but it's
also kind of the technical problem so
for example as a data sight is I have a
statistic back I have a background in
statistics so I talked a lot about
models and how can I improve them or a
distribution right where's the stuff
engineers probably talking about how can
I write a test
can this test pass or not right if you
ever face its program and of course due
to this problem due to the difference
that you have and sometimes take months
until a model is going to be in
production because the data scientists
have to understand the summary news and
the soreness has to understand the data
sine is and in many cases models will
never go into production at all because
they just hate each other
so what is the solution to this problem
well at pivotal labs we basically follow
an API first approach so what does API
first mean so API first means that try
to wrap everything as an API and create
microservices so in this case for
example you could have yeah
nice alright so you could write you
could have a one service that for
example do the prediction right you have
one server that cleans dator you have
one service that process theater you
have one service that that adds metadata
to it and you of course one serves that
consumes it an example for example there
could be like for example Amazon right
so what do what does Amazon do so they
do ecommerce you if you go in the Amazon
website you can buy the products and of
course another important element of of
their of their product is the
recommendation engine and basically
those services that I described could be
decoupled each other so you could have
one service that should serve as a
basket right and the other service is
the recommendation engine so what is the
advantage of this approach basically one
of the biggest advantage of course is
each team can focus what are they good
at so the data science can still use our
that can use Python that can use SAS
sequel and the sovereign genius that can
use Java that can just go the community
Swift so they don't need to learn
understand each other actually another
advantage is of course scalability so
because you create independent services
you can scale them up independently as
well so for example let's
say if you start a new startup right you
create a new website and of course when
you start the startup you don't have
many users but what happens when you go
to TechCrunch
right so when you attend TechCrunch you
you might get a lot of buzz and then of
course if you have this kind of a old
architecture right this could happen
that your your website would crash so
your customer experience will be quite
bad right and if you and in the in the
modern cloud native architecture I would
call it you don't have this problem
anymore so you can scale up your system
independently and you won't have this
problem another advantage of course as
you can see since you're decoupling your
your services each team can work on
smaller problems so that they can shift
the code faster no one to give you an
example because of course the this thing
of the set before is yeah it's quite
abstract so so for this example I
actually will use the famous
aDNA step data set so probably all of
you know it right it's on Cagle the data
set consists of 60,000 training and
10,000 testing images with the size of
28 times 28 and the problem is actually
to recognize handwritten numbers from 0
to 9 and yeah and so the the Deemer can
be found on my github account
unfortunately I only had two days to do
this so the documentation is still bad
so if you have any question afterwards
you can yeah right
write me or just yeah come by after the
talk so ok usually in our data science
engagement we actually have two phases
one phase is an exploration phase and
the other one is a production phase so
during typically doing an exploration
phase we actually experiment with a lot
of different models
and approaches to solve problem and this
face is usually not test-driven and we
use interactive tools like Jupiter
notebooks or or our studio or SAP Apache
Zeppelin to create motor prototypes or
just to get a visual understanding of
data like plotting it and in our example
the analyst problem is typically a
classification problem right because you
know the target class is isn't general
right from 0 to 9 and which basically
can solve by many approaches for example
you can use logistic regression you
could use a support vector machines or
anything else and but in this case we
actually using a deep learning a model
so particularly it is just a multi-layer
perceptron and a multi-layer perceptron
is basically just a feed-forward
artificial neural network and especially
good in learning nonlinear relations in
the data so as you can see on this graph
here in our case we feed images of
handwritten digits right with 28 times
28 and the input layer then we will have
some couple of hidden layers because as
I said it's a multi-layer perceptron so
it's more than one layer hidden layer
that we have and in the output layer we
will have several outputs because it's
not a it's not a binary classification
right in somatic class classification
and basically to create our models we
will use Chara's so Chara's is a deep
learning library written in python that
can be run on top of either theatre or
tenor flow and caris is especially
designed for fast prototyping and if you
haven't used it so far you should check
it out so it's a really cool library so
all right let's let's continue with the
daemon so of course first we load the
data luckily in this case because I was
just preparing this demo to show you
what API first means but luckily Chara's
has already some built-in data sets so
including the amnesty set which actually
is used to demonstrate Karis
capabilities using this option we can
easily load the data and get the train
and test data set and of course in
reality this is not straight forward
right so normally the data that we get
from our client is quite messy and we
actually spent a substantial amount of
time to understand the data to clean the
data and to transform the data as you
can see in this case basically what we
just did is we flattened the the the the
vector right and then we did some
transformation like for example
normalizing the future space to zero and
one as I said we got some images yet so
it's in RGB and if you if you know that
the intensity is from 0 to 200 255 right
u divided by 255 to normalize it between
0 and 1 and this is especially useful
because if you normalize it this is
faster for calculation in a neural
network so then we finally create the
MLP model so the multi-layer perceptron
model red so in this case as a set we
have two hidden layers we have troubled
at each the hidden layer and we use real
activation as you can see the input size
is 784 so similarly for because the
image size is 28 times 28 right so if
you multiply it you get 7 at 84 because
we just flattened the vector and for the
output layer we use softmax since it's a
multi-class problem if you for example
use the binary classification you
probably would use then a sigmoid
function so afterwards we train and
evaluate our model in this case we are
using accuracy as either evaluation
metrics so we the reason why I use
accuracy is that the class went
unbalanced so there were no person there
were quite balanced there were no
problems so that's why I didn't use
precision recall and
basically use batch size of one at 28
and just to add 20 epic so really
standard numbers for that and also I did
some in sample cross-validation and the
result that I got was pretty good
so was approximately 98% and based on
the model performance but usually in our
engagement we can actually try to
improve this model but in our case the
model is already performing quite well
so that we can use it for our further
app I would say and for our services and
basically what we do now is we restore
the model Kara's normally stores the
model separately so basically you have
network architecture that distorts and
also the model weights so now we know
that the model is performing quite well
but what happens now right so we if you
if you want to put a data science model
into production and want to use it by by
users they got to be something right
because in for that many data scientists
just just just try to play around right
do some plotting and something like this
it's it's really cool it's ok but if
it's not used every day it's going to
die anyway right so in this case we we
need to think about how to design
actually like an interaction point so
that can that we can use this model or
that that users can accept access this
model and as far as set we've been
working with images of 28 x 28 which is
probably not optimal right if you do an
app or like if you have a sketch pet in
this case so just imagine you have a
sketch the size of 28 times - aah so
it's really small so you can't draw
anything so it would be probably optimal
to increase the size of the images right
well the sketch pad where you can draw
something and if having those thoughts
in mind how to actually design this app
or API it would now make sense to - to
put this into production now and and
basically what we do at privileged
is we pair with sovereign genius so have
you guys heard of pair programming cool
that's cool
it's a very cool way to write code so
you should definitely try it out so the
next phase that we have it's called the
production phase at this stage we start
to do test-driven so and this is really
good because TDD helps actually to keep
our code base clean and trustworthy and
the user flow is like this we usually
rewrite failing test and then we make
the test pass right so and and then we
refactor a code and and then this
iteration goes again again until we are
satisfied with our code usually we
separate the code from the exploration
phase and production so if we we are
moving at bay basically actually from an
jupiter notebook two scripts right
because you cannot test tribute on
notebook right so probably it makes
sense to do it in a script and usually
we pair a lot than with suffer engineers
to develop this code in our example we
basically have three services so once
one serves that actually trains the
model and stores the output to a key
value store in this case I use Redis
which is a very simple cache layer so it
has also a very good connection to
Python and we have another one that
basically exposed the model as a restful
api and of course last one is there is
an app that basically consumes the api
and our case which is a sketch pad for
for exposing the model i use flash which
probably all of you know right so it is
a very lightweight web framework and
much easier than django and yeah in this
case what I did was I'm posting images
right - - to the API endpoint then what
I did as I said I need to resize or
convert the images in some way right
because
if you have like 28 states it's not
optimal so you increase the the the size
of the image and then you decrease it
again and then what I did here is I got
a model from Redis and then the model is
then used to to predict the the ditches
and then I returned if I get back is
basically the prediction for the
sketchpad basically my my colleague of
mine so from Alaska leek work on that so
she was using sketch yes which is a
simple camera based drawing tool for
jQuery to create the sketch pad and
basically it consumes from the
prediction API and to serve the
application we were using Sinatra which
was used which is written in Ruby so
yeah for for deployment and testing over
over apps we are using Cloud Foundry
actually we're using a development
version of Cloud Foundry so PCF def
which is just a smaller distribution of
PCF have you all heard of Pierre Cloud
Foundry do you know what it is yeah have
you heard of Heroku right okay so
California is similar to I would say
take the same idea as Heroku but he Roku
is like a public cloud right and whereas
if you use Cloud Foundry you can use it
also on a private cloud and this is
especially good if you are companying
right because they don't want to put
everything on the cloud so that is
actually the main difference so and
basically as what this quotes set read
so you you write your application right
you have a source code to you you just
do CF push so you use your command line
you do CF push and then it's just
running on cloud for you right and you
don't you don't care and you need to
care about anything else then so in this
case what what we do is we have like
these three applications right there's
the application we we need to write a
manifest yellow file so in this money if
I simplify you you define the name
of the app you define the dependencies
right so for example in the for example
for Ruby you need a ruby built pack for
Python you need a Python build pack and
essentially in a pile and pack which is
pretty pretty cool you just need to
write one line that it needs Python and
then you need just to put your
environment Yama file which you get from
Connor right and then what it does then
you do CF push it will go to this yeah
this area here to this block and then
what it does it basically pulls all the
dependencies from Connor for you
creates a container right and then what
it does it were created like we call it
a trap let it execute the app and then
it's just on line so it's really pretty
cool and it would take care of a lot of
things for example load balancing so you
don't need to take care of load
balancing you don't care about security
right you don't need to care about
routing so Cal foundry is taking care of
all of this
yeah so as you can see you can have a
free trial so you can register on our
free trial version so there's a free
trial version on run pivotal dot IO or
you it's actually 90 days I think so
just check it out or you could use the
PCF def version which is basically a
local virtual machine I did it so it's
also good it's free so it's worth trying
it out and on this Reaper here the gate
up river for my colleague he actually
has a lot of example of how to actually
push a Python app on Cloud Foundry and
there's actually this super amazing talk
from one of our technical program
manager about CF from his called on Z
it's really good YouTube videos so check
it out right and as a CI and CD tool so
you you know all of you guys know what
CI and CD means
okay so CIS stands for continuous
integration and CD stands for continuous
delivery usually in a sovereign earring
you you we work with get bread so or any
version control so what we do is we try
to integrate code as much as possible
especially if you work in a team right
if you if you don't do this you will get
a lot of merge and errors and suddenly
this and continuous delivery is
basically extending the CIA idea right
so you want to have production ready
code as early as possible right so you
just need to push anything and then it
will be deployed and the advantage which
so we are we're using conquer CI and the
advantage with conquer CI is you can
create pipelines and basically the test
environment
Duggars so hence if you if you use this
the tests always starts from scratch and
this is good because if you ever use
Jenkins or Travis or something this
before you know that you will get some
kind of a share test environment right
so you cannot reuse it again or you have
to really initiate your your-your-your
Jenkins again and of course one of the
reason why we use it it's a natively
supports Cloud Foundry and also a very
cool thing is you like Jenkins is a very
web-based CI tool whereas if you use
conquer CI it's you can programmatic or
your pipeline so it's as essentially
just a Yama file in this picture you can
see that we actually have two spaces so
one is for testing and the other one is
for production and the production in
this case is only triggered if there's a
new tech version of the code for example
on get up well and this is this makes a
sense because as you might do some yeah
well it is my career sense because you
might do some user tests right for your
app with a small amount of users instead
of all users in production right so this
is so testing is not about all code
testing right it's all about also about
interface and app testing so this is
also important yeah so basically this is
a live and this is the app this is a
demo of the app which I which is hosted
on
GWS so I actually can go to this one so
basically you have four buttons so it's
a marker razor download and predict and
let me also open inspect oh man okay
this is not optimal
okay it's not a good idea so you I can't
receive the the prediction endpoint but
for example when I just draw something
right so what the [ __ ] oh okay
so there's an there's an uh there's
something so basically what it does this
is this is a this is an application
which one donors own services right and
then you have their prediction API which
also is also an independent service and
basically it's just connect to each
other so every time you you you write
something you sent the picture to the
add point right so it's basically two
different services that is running and
you can basically scale it up
independently which is pretty cool right
if you like for example I have a lot of
load and a future it's elastic right so
you can scale instances if you have more
people coming to this website and yeah
of course it's it's actually it's not
perfect so for example I think I always
have a problem with four so and also my
handwriting is not very good so just
bear with it so if you dig okay this was
a good thing I don't know yeah
because usually when I do four sometimes
I get a lot of eights so because I'm not
quite sure what's happening but of
course this was a very simple data set
right and the model was also pretty
simple actually if you go into lagoon's
website so he's he's doing a lot into
this area with an image classification
and so on you would get actually
different models better models so
basically you can also use in this model
okay
victimís lights okay all right so this
what are the key takeaways of this
presentation well so put models into
production right because then they are
then there's a high chance that they are
that they survive and I buy used by
users right this is a very important try
to use API right try to create services
because this is easier and this is
better for four different teams because
they can they can connect to each other
without understanding each other it's
like it's like I think like a
relationship between I don't know like a
girl a boy right try to say find
something where you can connect to each
other and of course think about wrapping
your data science model as early as
possible and yeah of course so deploy
your code as early and as often as
possible so that users can test it and
give earlier in regular feedback use a
suitable continuous delivery tool that
automatically deploy your your code so
try to do this even if you're not
familiar with this it is really worth it
so I'm actually also don't have her
background in solar engineering but I
learned a lot from my colleagues in a
pivotal apps so it's really great it
really helps us to to write better code
and also to deploy things faster and if
you if you don't want to use concurs
it's okay there are many other tools
outside right there Trevor's there
Jenkins try out one of them do TDD
so when I started with with at labs I
was really really yea confused about
testing right so if you have a
background in statistics you know you're
like what what is the test why do I have
to test my code you know it's like why
do I do need to do that but it really
helped me to actually improve my coat
and
and it's really useful so we have a lot
of blocks actually on pivotal
engineering about how to write tests so
this is also worth checking it out and
of course TDD is actually not
appropriate for for all data science
phases right so I had this phase split
between exploration phase and production
phase so is it from from from our from
my experiences TDD is not useful if you
are in a exploration phase so if you're
trying to to experiment and and and and
with different models and solving your
problem right and but it is very useful
if you put your code into production
right because just imagine if you have
to change something later in your
pipeline it really improves actually to
to to to to change the code without
having to worry that something might
fail and yeah that's it thank you for
the yeah thank you yeah two questions
here first there was a talk yesterday on
using like a different framework other
than like Django and I think it was like
calm for curtain or something what would
Falken or had something like bird name
anyway it was okay
it was it was kind of take the approach
of it of like when you your micro survey
starts to get a lot of hits likes
particularly the data science thing
instead of like scaling it up why
scaling the number of instances are
using like multi-threading basically and
if you had a problem with that it's all
like with the tooth getting too many
hits on your API or basically there
won't be any problem because you can
scale them up very easily because
basically what what Cloud Foundry it
does right you can just do CF scale
instances right and then they create a
an exact container of that what you did
of the API endpoint
and if you probably of course if you if
you hit like some kind of threshold
where where where things might break
right what god only does it will restart
the service so that's a cool thing
actually with this hi so that that
resonated with me with the whole
throwing away models are for a few
months thing so my question is like the
the stuff that you showed have you got
like a step-by-step tutorial on your
github repository and basically as I
said the documentation is currently not
perfect so I had limited time but I
actually wrote a and like a block on it
so if you Google API and then first as
written
not not API first and then pivotal
engineering block then you will find
something where you can read it but of
course what I will do afterwards is I
try to extend my documentation right
yeah so and just quickly so the app that
you showed me is it running on a free
server or is it basically you it's it's
running on PWS which is pivotal web
service and prover web service is like a
car foundry on AWS and yeah right but of
course you can use your own cloud
foundry instance so this boundary is
open source right so you don't need to
use the the product by pebble right it
is an open source project right you can
download californee and also use it at
your company another question
all right let's thank our speaker that
trend was well thank you